Pastor, what would you say about
Christians with credit cards? Doesn't
the Bible say "Owe no man"?
Many call themselves Christians, but
they go around using others and holding
on to their money while making others
suffer. I want these so-called
Christians to hear the answer to this
question and to learn and share. It will
please God, I believe, and thank you.
Well, I I don't know if my answer will
be what you expect.
I have a credit card.
You see,
there This is good counsel to avoid
debt, of course.
But,
most of us today
have to acquire the things we need on
some kind of installment plan.
And that is not dishonest.
It is not the fact that you buy on
installment plan. It is when you refuse
to keep your word and pay according to
your promise
that you do wrong.
And so, credit cards are blessing.
As a matter of fact, they give us cards
to use from our office so that you don't
have to keep carrying a lot of money
with you. So, it's not really wrong to
have a credit card. The problem is when
you refuse to keep your word and pay
according to the contract.
And and honestly, I don't see how that
causes anybody else to suffer
as long as a Christian keeps his word.
Thank you.
Pastor, here's an interesting question.
Why do so many of the women in your
church dress so plainly?
I told uh
I told Pastor Ortiz I was going to have
to have some time with this.
Because I imagine I have had 15 or 20
questions
about how a Christian ought to dress.
And I said, perhaps we won't answer so
many questions tonight. We'll just deal
with this one.
Is that all right?
Now, I want you to
jot down the references I give you
because
you will want to settle this in your
heart
once and for all. And I want to tell you
something, God never sends his truth to
embarrass
or to offend, but to enlighten. Is that
all right?
Now, the first text I want you to write
down is Proverbs 8 and verse 13.
There the Bible says, "The fear of the
Lord is to hate evil
and pride and arrogancy."
If you want to really
fear the Lord, then you learn to hate
evil
and to hate pride and arrogancy.
A Christian
is not to be a proud person.
Write down Proverbs 6 and verse 16.
There the Bible says, "Six things God
hates, yea, seven are an abomination,
and the first is pride." What is it?
Pride.
Don't forget these texts, and there are
many others like that.
Now, sin began in heaven,
and it is a mystery.
If it could be explained, it could
probably be accepted.
But, it is a mystery. It was totally
uncalled for.
But, when we consider the history of
sin, we find a perfect God
in a perfect heaven
with a perfect angel in a perfect
environment
with perfect company.
Are you with me?
Now, how on earth could sin begin
in an atmosphere like that?
Well, I want to tell you that pride very
well could be called the father
of sin.
The first sin.
First John chapter 2 verses 15 and 16,
the Bible says, "Love not the world,
neither the things that are in the
world."
And then it goes on to tell us what
those things are. "For all that is in
the world, the lust of the flesh, the
lust of the eyes, and the pride of life.
Pride of life is not of the Father, but
is of the world."
And then the next verse says, "The world
passeth away." So, beloved, a Christian
who is a Christian is by nature a humble
person who subdues and conquers pride.
These texts are very clear.
Now, you really don't have to learn
pride. It seems we are born with it.
Pride is a great evil, and God names it
number one amongst the seven which to
him are an abomination.
Now, God has a program to mitigate
pride.
And we who know God's word enter into
God's program, and we fight against
pride in our lives by obedience to God's
standards.
Would you say amen out there?
And don't ever consider anything that
God does to be insignificant or
unnecessary.
God has an arrangement with his people
to help them overcome pride and
arrogancy
until
this world has passed away.
I want to tell you right now, when we
get to heaven, we going to wear gold on
our heads.
Crowns of gold.
With stars in the crown. Would somebody
say amen?
There is no sin in things.
Sin is in people.
And God has a system that helps us fight
against that.
Now, let me just cover several things
while I'm at it.
Jesus said, "I didn't come to destroy
the law, but to fulfill.
I came to demonstrate in my life and
teachings what real obedience is all
about." And Jesus said, "You have heard
it said
that if a man murder his brother or
kills his brother, he's a murderer. I
say unto you, if you hate your brother,
you are a murderer."
So, Christ is enlarging.
Amen?
And amongst other things he said, "You
have heard that if a man commits
adultery with a woman, he has done this
awful sin. But, I say unto you, if you
look at a woman
to lust after her, you have committed
adultery already in your heart." Now,
Christians ought not to have any trouble
saying amen to that.
Now, the reason I picked that out is
because God wants Christian women to
dress in a way that does not invite
lust.
All right?
Now, the Bible rule is not inches, but
it is a principle called modesty.
I was down in a foreign land once, and I
noticed all the ladies that I
seemed to recognize had on funny-looking
dresses. They They were not long enough
to be long and not short enough to be
normal.
And I okay, if that's what they want to
wear, it's all right with me. And so,
finally,
somebody began to ask me questions. How
many inches should your dress be off the
ground?
And I said what I said now, God doesn't
deal in inches, he deals in principles.
And the principle is modesty.
Christian women should be modest. Would
you have a disagreement with that?
Modest.
And frankly, that's a relative term.
If you are buxom, modesty for you might
be different than for a very slender
lady.
God's principle is modesty in dress
so that women do not become
unnecessarily a temptation to men.
Well, it didn't seem to satisfy some of
the folk. And finally, I met the man
responsible for it.
He was teaching on that island that
every dress had to be exactly 9 inches
off the ground.
I thought it totally ridiculous.
God doesn't deal in inches.
You'd have to carry a ruler around all
day and keep measuring because dresses
ride up.
But, while we disallow that kind of
incredible foolishness, ladies and
gentlemen, God expects men and women to
be modest.
And we are living in an immodest age.
The designers of clothes are not
necessarily Christian.
They are commercial, and if they make
dresses this year, they got to change it
for next year, or else they can't make
any money.
So, all of a sudden, immodesty is
everywhere, and it becomes the norm.
And when you look around, their
shoulders out,
bosoms out,
backs out,
thighs out,
toes out,
look out.
This is an immodest
age, and people's minds are obsessed
with clothing and appearance.
Some are even slaves to it.
All the money they can get a hold of,
and that which they don't even have.
Maybe that's what that question was
about with these credit cards. MONEY
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE.
THEY JUST HAVE TO BUY, BUY, BUY, BUY,
BUY. AND I tell you, it's not always
easy to find the right thing,
because the trend is immodest.
Now, I've got one of those darling wives
who wants me to go shopping with her.
I'll whisper to you all that I don't
like to do that.
I do it,
but I don't like to do it, because women
shop funny. They'll walk your legs off
and won't buy a thing.
But I enjoy her company, so I go with
her. Now, I'm something of an artist,
and I appreciate texture and design. And
sometimes, while she's looking, I'm
looking. And I'll see a color that I
know will compliment her lovely brown
skin.
And I'll go over AND PULL IT OFF. And
when I look at it, it dips all the way
down, IT HAS A SLIT ALL THE WAY THERE'S
NO NEED ASKING HER TO TRY that on. HANG
IT UP.
IT'S IMMODEST.
Others may, she cannot.
Not because she's my wife, necessarily,
but because she is a Christian.
Now, when you say our lady is a plain,
it generally holds that Christian ladies
in our church do not burden themselves
with superfluous jewelry.
Now, please remember what I told you.
God doesn't send the truth to embarrass
you,
but to enlighten you.
And I wish you'd remember, too, my
family wasn't born in this thing. We
learned it just like you learned it.
By listening to the word of the Lord and
studying it out for ourselves.
I want to read something to you. It to
me, it is very clear. I'm going to the
book of Isaiah. What book did I say?
And it's chapter 3. And I want you By
the way, I read from an archaeologist
that Isaiah lived across the street from
a beauty parlor.
How did they know? Because they found
Isaiah's house, and directly across,
they found all kinds of pieces of broken
mirror,
combs, and pins. So, the scholars
conclude there was a beauty parlor
across street, and Isaiah
took notice of this.
I want you to listen. Isaiah chapter 3,
and I'm beginning with verse 16. Now,
I'm taking a little time. Write it down.
The Bible says, "Moreover, the Lord
saith." Who saith?
Don't you ever blame this on a
denomination.
"Moreover, the Lord saith,
because the daughters of Zion." What is
Zion?
Church.
"The Lord saith, because the daughters
of Zion are haughty." They're what?
That's a synonym for proud.
"Because the daughters of Zion are
haughty, and walk with stretched forth
necks." What does that mean? No need
rushing through this.
It means they're so proud, they got
their noses in the air.
"They walk with stretched forth necks
and wanton eyes." What does that mean?
Trying to look sexy.
You see how clear it is? The Lord says,
"Because the daughters of the church are
haughty,
and walk with stretched forth necks AND
WANTON EYES, WALKING and mincing as they
go."
Now, I want to be very frank and not
indelicate
in this company.
Women are different than men.
Praise the Lord.
As girls enter into puberty, they become
rounded and curvaceous and soft, and
they have wider hips to accommodate
childbirth.
Men generally become angular, and in
many cases, broad-shouldered, and so
forth. They are different. God made them
different.
God intends that they be different.
Now, when a lady walks normally and
naturally, her walk is different than a
man's walk,
automatically,
because of the way she is built.
But have you ever noticed how some, when
they get on a dress that's sufficiently
tight and revealing, they actually
They they they
Their walk is no longer normal.
It is exaggerated.
Now, I'm trying to be careful, but you
understand me, don't you? The Bible
says, "Walking and mincing as they go,
and making a tinkling with their feet."
Verse 17.
"Therefore, the Lord." Who?
"Will smite with a scab the crown of the
head of the daughters of Zion, and the
Lord will discover their secret parts."
What does that mean? It's a reference,
the commentators say, to social diseases
which follow in the trail of immodesty.
"The Lord will discover their secret
parts. In that day, verse 18, the Lord
will take away the bravery of their
tinkling ornaments about their feet, and
their cauls, and their round tires like
the moon, the chains and the bracelets
and the mufflers, the bonnets and the
ornaments of the legs and the headbands
and the tablets and the earrings." And
what?
"The rings, verse 21, and nose jewels."
In our country now, you see people push
holes in their noses and wear little
studs.
"And nose jewels, the changeable suits
of apparel and the mantles and the
wimples and the crisping pins and the
glasses and the fine linen and the hoods
and the veils and all of these
in that culture had a meaning, and many
of these things are in our culture, and
God says, "These are superfluous
adornings, and they exacerbate the
problem of pride amongst God's people."
And the Bible says, "In that day,"
referring to the day of judgment, God
will snatch it away.
Now, this is not the only reference.
In the book of Genesis 35 and verse 2,
when Jacob's family was traveling and
trouble began to follow them,
they were told to put away their strange
gods. And in verse 4, it says, "And
Jacob,"
or rather, they gave Jacob all of their
strange gods and all of their earrings
in their ears, and they were hidden
under an oak. God got rid of that so
that he could come to the defense of his
people.
Now, ladies and gentlemen,
when Moses went up in the mountain
to commune with God,
they heard a noise in the valley, and
God broke off communications. He told
Moses, "GO GET THEE DOWN, FOR THY PEOPLE
that thou broughtest out of the land of
Egypt have corrupted themselves." And
Moses said, "Lord, let not thine anger
wax hot against thy people." You see it?
God said to Moses, "Look, these are your
people." Moses said, "No, Lord, THEY'RE
YOUR PEOPLE." YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU CORRUPT
YOURSELF, NOBODY WANTS YOU. Would you
say amen out there?
And when Moses came down, he found them
bowing down and worshiping a golden
calf.
Now, these folk had just come out of
Egypt, so they decided to dress up like
the Egyptians did.
And they loaded themselves with jewelry,
and they were immodest. The Bible says,
"They played with all their might." And
in the original, says, "Leaping and
dancing." They learned how to dance in
Egypt. That's where the belly dance came
from.
And God was ready to destroy them.
And Moses began to intercede for them,
and finally, God had mercy. After the
golden calf was destroyed, a judgment
came, and many MANY OF THEM DIED. NOT
ONLY THAT, THE firstborn lost the
privilege of priesthood. It was GIVEN TO
THE LEVITES. And now, God's anger began
to go away. And God said that they were
to take off their ornaments. Are you
listening?
God says, "Take off your ornaments, that
I might know what to do with you." This
is found in Exodus 33
and the Bible says they stripped
themselves by heart. They took them off.
AT A TIME OF JUDGEMENT
AT A TIME WHEN THEY WERE IN DANGER OF
BEING JUDGED FOREVER.
It was necessary
in order to please God to take this off.
We are living
in the time of the judgement. Somebody
say amen.
It is time for us to look like what we
profess to be.
One man said, "If you believe in the
redeemer, you ought to look redeemed."
Now, we're going on.
The Bible tells us,
I don't have time to go through them
all. You ask some questions, I'll give
you some more, but I want to go to the
New Testament. What did I say?
Because there are people who always want
to give everything to the Jews and they
want to get rid of everything they don't
want to do by saying that's the Old
Testament. Well, I'm going to the new
and the Bible says this in 1 Timothy
chapter 2 and verse 9. I want you to
listen. This is the New Testament.
And the Bible says in verse 9 of chapter
2 of 1 Timothy in like manner also
that women adorn themselves Adorn means
dress.
That women adorn themselves in modest
apparel with shamefacedness and
sobriety, not with braided hair
or gold or pearls or costly array.
Would you say amen?
Now, that's been in the Bible all these
centuries. It isn't God's fault that you
don't know it.
John Wesley, the father of Methodism,
and I was a Methodist. John Wesley said
not one cent should be spent on
superfluous adornings and gildings.
That was the teaching of the Methodist
Church.
In fact, many of the things you've heard
out here were taught by the early
reformers.
But as the churches have kept turning
AWAY FROM GOD'S LAW, THEY HAVE ADOPTED A
LIFESTYLE THAT EVEN their founders did
not approve of.
And that's what John Wesley taught. The
New Testament says that we ought to
dress as women professing godliness.
That's verse 10.
Not with gold or pearls or costly array.
Now, I'm going over to the book of 1
Peter. What book did I say?
Chapter 3, please listen. 1 Peter
chapter 3 and I'm beginning with verse
1. Likewise, you wives
be in subjection to your own husbands
that if any obey not the word, they also
may without the word be won by the
conversation of the wives. And the word
conversation in the Greek means conduct.
Are you with me?
While they behold your chaste
conversation or conduct coupled with
fear. Verse 3, whose adorning dressing
whose adorning let it not be that
outward adorning of plating the hair and
of wearing of gold or putting on of
apparel, but let it be the hidden man of
the heart and that which is not
corruptible, even the ornament of a meek
and quiet spirit which is in the sight
of God of great price. For after this
manner in the old time, the holy women
What kind of women?
The holy women also who trusted in God
adorned themselves.
Now, this is the New Testament, beloved.
God sends truth to enrich us. I want to
conclude this. I don't have time to give
you everything, but I want to conclude
this by telling you that what we ought
to avoid in our appearance is
artificiality.
There's nothing wrong with being
attractive.
As a matter of fact, there's a
difference between being attractive and
being beautiful.
A person can be attractive without being
beautiful.
I'm a I'm a connoisseur of beauty in
women.
And as an authority, I want to tell you
I have never seen an ugly woman.
They make themselves ugly by their
attitudes. On the other hand, I have
seen some handsome women who were ugly
because they were so snooty.
They made you feel like you owed them a
debt just to look at them.
What makes a woman attractive? I'll give
you some hints. A beautiful smile
a clear conscience a friendly attitude a
Christian demeanor
YOU CAN BE ATTRACTIVE AND PEOPLE ENJOY
being around you without your being
beautiful.
Amen.
Now, if you are beautiful, there's
nothing wrong with that. But if you
aren't, just keep yourself clean,
well-groomed and love Jesus so much that
he shines through your countenance and
people WILL FIND YOU ATTRACTIVE
AND WILL BEAT A PATH TO YOUR DOOR.
FINALLY
THERE are some things that are
classified jewelry which are
utilitarian.
A watch is one of those things.
Uh it it serves a purpose.
And there are other such things. Uh
there are some people who stumble over
everything. I don't try to make
everything wrong.
You see, the there are Pharisees amongst
us
who think you shouldn't even wear a tie
pin. I got a little tiny tie pin. The
reason I got it is so when I'm
preaching, my tie won't dance to and fro
so that you will notice my tie rather
than listening to what I got to say.
So, those things which are useful,
utilitarian generally are acceptable as
long as you don't go to extremes. It
would be wrong for me to spend $10,000
for a diamond tie tack. Would you say
amen? And you can rest assured I don't
do that. Now, this one was given to me
by a fine man who's sitting here now.
Uh he maybe he paid 10,000. Maybe he'll
tell me he did.
But I can tell you when I buy one, it
doesn't cost that.
Now, you see how reasonable God's
program is?
AND WHEN YOU FIRST PUT ON LIPSTICK
YOU FEEL so self-conscious
because it's unnatural.
When you first DO A LOT OF THINGS, you
feel that way because it's unnatural. We
were not born with purple fingernails.
It's unnatural. Keep your fingernails
polished and clean and clear and and
shined up and clipped and shaped, but
you don't need black fingernails.
They got fingernails now with palm trees
on them.
And mountains and sunsets.
You don't need that.
Amen.
There ought to be a difference when you
look at a Christian lady
than when you look at one who isn't.
And God said there would be a difference
amongst the people because of him.
And as an
as an expert on beauty, I want to tell
you you don't need it.
You don't need it.
Only the enemy makes you think you do.
And once you've been used to it for a
while, you feel a little funny till you
get used to not having it on.
And that's why the ladies in our church
who are faithful look plain.
But don't they look good?
I've been married to a beautiful woman
for a long time and even though we're
getting older, she's still beautiful.
She is to me and you better believe it.
And as we get older still, she'll be
beautiful.
And she has never had to depend on those
things. How many of you appreciate that
answer to the Lord's the Lord's answer
to your question? If you do, say amen.